okay we're just waiting right now for
our instructor to join us so I'm going
to uh
keep on hold for just a couple more
minutes
the meantime I'm going to start our live
stream
all right
and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience as well as YouTube live and
folks here on
WebEx
we'll be starting in just a couple
moments
mentioned I'm waiting for
our instructor to join us here he is
sorry
just joined
yes and we're live thank you Eric Bender
um
the
as I mentioned we are here for our
interview prep Master Class
um while low level coding is vital in
software interviews with top companies
we have changed it from
data structures and algorithms at the
request Ventra
so that he can cover this topic we'll
cover DSA also in the
later webinar
next month but we wanted to talk about
LLC which is a vital
um skill set to have and to put forward
in software interviews so we'll be
talking about that today if you're in
the WebEx
session please put your questions for
our vendor into the Q a panel and we'll
take those at the Q a toward the end of
the red webinar
and uh you can chat with him uh at all
panelists
um you have a comment or observation but
your questions should go in the Q a
panel so that we can get those if you're
watching on streaming please put those
into your streaming comment box or chat
box and we'll somebody will transfer
those over to us for us to respond
so we're also going to ask you a poll
question
and at the beginning at the end
this one is
just to get a feel for who's in our
audience today
and this is how much work experience you
have not necessarily in software
development but just within the the
workplace itself
um
if you're still looking at school about
that but we'd like to get an idea of how
much experience people have in the
working environment and also we're
checking in as we have been throughout
the pandemic on how people are
feeling
the
was a confusing time with lockdowns
coming going surges and coming and going
and here's the poll result
and the full result is
um everybody's a fresher today we don't
have that many people with a lot of work
experience uh
Rec vendor that gives you an idea who
are who's in our audience these are
people who are eager to prepare for
starting their career or moving up early
in their career and that's going to be
great uh
we'll start right now oops before this
I'm going to go ahead stop sharing my
screen and allow you to share yours and
introduce yourself
so
here's the Sharon privilege
thank you so much in just a second
uh sure thing
and you had uh
asked to change the subject from DSA to
LLC so
we'll talk about LLC today but uh
go ahead yeah it's it's actually lld so
sorry uh I'm sorry that's okay so uh
I'll I'll explain everything why I have
J Tropic and stuff so this is also very
important for interviews so nowadays if
you see a lot of places you find those
users of data set that I'll be covering
again in the next webinar whenever it
comes up okay
so before I start with that um
let me introduce myself to all of you
guys in just a second I'll just share my
screen
okay so I hope everything is visible to
you guys
good so I will try to keep it as easy as
possible because there are a lot of
pressures in here
but nowadays Industries are moving
towards dynamically uh towards very
much towards the design phase like I'll
tell you why I'll take you forward
before that let me introduce myself here
in this part of this slide
so this is importance of low level
design in interviews okay
which is very useful if you have at
least two to three years of experience
but it's always good that you have this
idea in your mind okay this is coming
towards us at later point of time what
and all we need to keep our keep our
mindset towards learning this okay that
is the main agenda behind picking this
topic okay talking about me uh myself
ragbendra likes Stuart mentioned I am
currently over nine years of experience
in that industry and I am working as a
staff a software engineer in one of the
fortunate companies and I've conducted
multiple training sessions I keep taking
uh
a lot of training sessions across simply
learn another to other uh other edtech
Industries
so that is the main uh close to four
years I am doing this particular
sessions okay one second
sorry yeah welcome back
yeah yeah so
so I will continue
so please agenda is mainly on someone
came in my door that's why I just did
that
is about what are the importance first
of all what is lower level design high
level design okay I'll just stop my uh
video with webcam because I am very
limited bandwidth from my side
so don't mind for that where is this how
do I
okay
thank you so my main point of discussion
today is
what is this low level design people
always talk about and there are two
things comes in okay so before if go
forward in that point I want to make
sure all of you understand this point
thoroughly well okay there are two
aspects of it okay one is
I'll bring my notepad here
level design
other one is lower level design I I
don't I didn't wanted to prepare the
site for this specifically because I
want to write and show these things to
you okay so whenever we think about uh
eye level design right we have design
design Maybe
I took one of the sessions then
Instagram
okay that question is asked can you
speak about a lot of it's about what
requirements are do we really want for
this okay so it goes in this direction
that means it can be functional it can
be non-functional and you talk about
memory estimates
it means how much memory is for profile
how much memory it takes for the same
profile for a month and all those things
and then we talk about
high level design here
and then we go about detailed design
and then we talk about bottlenecks that
means if we go with this what
bottlenecks we can face this is what oil
level design talks about why I am
telling this I'm giving you a context of
what is this
high level design assets so this can be
designed Instagram design YouTube
or
design
anything it can be any of such things
design
dot URL or tiny URL
how that happens
Etc this this goes on okay these kind of
questions are generally as linear
system design interviews mainly when we
gain that experience of somewhere around
two to three years okay
starting that they will ask you okay if
you are preparing for a fan companies
right
foreign companies
okay current situation about these
companies slightly dicey definitely
things will change okay again when we
prepare for such companies our
preparation will be on the top notch
okay we will be our best to give the
interview for our such companies at
least if we prepare in that way we'll be
able to land in some good companies okay
so this is what mainly enable design is
mainly talks about overall system design
okay that is why we call it as
hld okay and then it is also known as
macro level or system design
whereas lld mainly focuses on
the component level designs you go to
the past level okay what class you use
how do you use what is the benefits of
the classes and all those things so
that's where this
low level design comes into place okay
it's like
detailed
component design okay our component
level design
I'll give an example
for example let's say I am building
a product okay a car can be an
automobile right first of all I'll have
an automobile interface in place or a
bank in place and then that spreads out
across multiple banks for example I have
one bank and I have three other Banks
under it ICICI htfc and Canada okay now
these three banks are there they inherit
some properties from them okay now like
this there can be multiple things in
future
how do we kind of extract some common
patterns in this and make it as a
standard that is what we mainly focus on
this low level design and that is why it
is very important okay this is also
known as micro level or detailed design
okay important point and then
if you see
generally these things are created by
your
architects
that means you get to work with them you
understand with them what is this if you
are an employee you will definitely get
a good Hands-On of these things okay and
generally in this mainly participants
would be who understand these are little
senior members okay who are having
maybe I would say three to four
Plus
okay plus can be a very big range
okay and can go up to 20 years of
experience also
Okay so
that's in this
this one it is mainly the functional
logic okay any developer who has good
grasp of it
can work on this okay this is not
restricted for that this is mainly
designers
and developers work on this
okay
for interviews
it's very important if you are a fresher
they focus not on this they focus more
on this as your experience grows your
questions will be mainly focused on this
so this is where initial interviews will
be focused on okay because you guys
speak a lot about coding than about
design you guys talk about majorly I
implemented this logic in this code then
they'll ask you okay good that
implemented all these logic in your code
can you just tell me did you observe any
problems in that and did you suggested
any solution for that in your system
that is what the question will be asked
you and now to answer that you need to
identify those patterns now only okay
you need to start building your
intellect now only to think towards this
aspect of it okay so that is why lld is
very important and
you will be part of this
Journey once you become two to three
year of experience and it goes forward
nowadays Market is so much in demand you
need to understand everything your
freshness are sometimes as questions to
understand of course not to judge you
but to understand where you stand in
these things
okay so I've just given you the brief of
it if you guys have any questions in
this I am open to take these questions
my voice is very low is that true Stuart
you can you hear me clearly
uh I hear you pretty clearly
okay
Okay
so
I'll move forward then I'll talk about
these things and I'll go very slow and
I'll explain about each and every topic
and I'll show for one single design
pattern how do we go about coding also
I'll open my editor I'll start writing
the problem statement and I'll explain
you what that can be done for such
situations maybe we will pick one small
design and we'll try to design that also
in this one hour okay so okay so what is
design I have a lot of things in my
slides okay but I'll try to cover
aspects as possible but also go for
practical demonstration for the same
agenda is what is design patterns what
are advantages of knowing the original
design patterns which design patterns
named in the retreating and what are the
key ideas of those patterns okay these
are the main agenda or the mindset
behind today's session
now
first of all
BP design pattern may be problems in
your system whatever it is
before solving a problem
sorry before solving anything we need to
know for what problem statement we are
trying to give the solution okay it is
important no matter you write a DSA code
and you write a design code you write
whatever it is it is very important for
us to understand what problem are we
solving here okay is it really important
for us to understand in that detail yes
that level of understanding one must
possess to get things running in your
mind okay that is why I mentioned this
point
designing the software for reuse is hard
one must find a good problem
decomposition and the right software
very important Point remember this this
is the statement which tells you how to
pick a problem statement so that you can
work on it okay you need to make sure
that design is flexible modular and
elegant okay in future days maybe I will
pick up one more Master Class they will
talk about solid principles okay but
this is very important I will I will not
be able to spend time on this because it
itself is a day on its own so I'll look
up that topic some other day but you
need to follow all these five desired
principles to make sure you write a good
software okay and design often this is a
true fact people some people don't agree
with me but I definitely want to
highlight this point designs definitely
emerge from trialed errors sometimes you
go and try some XYZ design okay writing
patterns it might not actually come out
successful okay yes you have to
not get bogged down continue with your
journey for finding the right design
okay
I'll give you an example for this why
this is going wrong
have you heard of lot of Google
softwares failed okay out of 10 to 15
whatever Google have launched hardly two
three have picked up I'll tell you an
example of what and all Google have
closed out have you heard Google Duo
Google classroom
these are the software these are the
products Google have launched okay but
they didn't pick up because their
competitors have solved the problem
better than what they did
okay so I'm giving you an example of if
you don't think right you may end up in
problems and this is what
trial and error me all about okay
likewise there are extremely successful
projects are also there for example
Google pay is a very profitable business
for them Gmail
Google Cloud all these are very
profitable business because they find
the right
tune for that particular thing in the
market which will go and get them big
money
okay even successful design do exist
okay two designs they are almost never
identical okay you've if you have 10
designs if you make
trust me there will be some minute
difference between even though two
appears to be exactly same
topic or like exactly copy of another
but it will not be there will be some
minor differences you will find they
exhibit some recurring characteristics
for sure so this is the point we try to
address in our journey of design okay so
now what one more challenge is
and Designs we described codified or
standardized okay very very tricky
question okay this would Short Circuit
the trial and error face okay because a
person who knows this design patterns
prayer is able to do better decision I
am not telling here that he will be able
to make the correct decision exactly but
he will be able to make a better
decisions than the person who doesn't
understand actual design patterns he
will just randomly make some pictures
which are not really helpful
okay that is the reason
we can't standardize them yes there are
some patterns we create and we keep it
but
those patterns can be used to get our
complex design okay of course building
Twitter okay or building any building
hot star or any such websites doesn't
happen is a very simple knowledge of
whatever you have it requires a lot of
trial and error trial and error and lot
of those uh like even Flipkart also in
that case in Flipkart how many times
you've ended up in 404 error pages in
Amazon
Pages it's quite common right why that
happens because you definitely make some
mistakes and that will end up in such
problems and that is okay no one is
blaming us yes that is why we call it as
production issues as a software company
okay we deal with it we go we fix this
problems okay that is the reason
if we skip that error parent interface
slightly we can short circuit those
steps of making premature answers for
those questions okay if you know such
things you can produce better software
faster look at the word usage here
better software faster okay that plays a
very important role I will save the PPT
with all of you guys don't worry after
the class you will be shared all the
materials with you guys okay I've made
this for your purpose only okay
don't worry you don't have to ask me to
go back to previous slides I will be
sharing these slides to you with you as
you guys only you can refer this any
point of time okay people who are asking
me this question
okay now what is a design pattern first
of all we all need to understand that
okay desired pattern is a common
solution
to a common software problem in a given
context
that is what it is
problem can be anything okay I will come
to one pattern unless and justify
whatever statements I'm making here okay
so before I go there I'll talk about
this
it describes a recurring software
structure what that means what does that
means
let us say we keep on trying to get same
implementation for a same problem
statement why can't we standardize that
okay that is what this definition is
saying you are describing a recurring
software structure
is is also part of
design pattern okay it is an abstract
from programming language what is an
abstract
just like I shown you an agenda here
right
today we're going to discuss this
and you guys add something in your mind
yes today we're gonna learn what is
design pattern so this given me a
pattern that I will follow these steps
in sequence that is what exactly I
mentioned this particular Point says
it's an abstract from a programming
language
okay and then it identifies classes and
their roles in the solution to a problem
we going to identify
some recurring software structure with
the help of classes and what are their
roles in the solution whatever we're
going to give to a problem that is what
is
a design pattern okay and patterns are
not code or designs it must be
instantiated or applied for example
iterator pattern what you guys might
have definitely used iterator pattern
here in your code in your experience I
am pretty sure about it
okay
to ask me where everywhere okay
iterators are in Java or very commonly
used if you know collections okay in the
collections we have enumerator we have
list iterator
and iterator okay
what this will do we will discuss that
next
what are the benefits of using this
patterns one must understand just not
knowing this okay we need to really
understand the underneath layer of this
what is the purpose if I use my design
patterns what I am going to gain is once
you understand okay patterns are common
design vocabulary you know what is
vocabulary
I have to speak right I have to speak
correct okay that means I need to know
the vocabulary what I'm using or
speaking right like we speak
the right coding techniques also needs a
correct design vocabulary to write
correct Solutions that's where design
comes in place and pattern comes in
place it allows Engineers to abstract
the problem and talk about that
abstraction in isolation from its
implementation this is very important
okay like I told you what it does it
allows Engineers to abstract the problem
you
extract the brief of it and you mention
it
as a isolated solution for the given
problem statement okay also it embodies
a culture domain specific patterns to
increase design speed if you know
certain problems solution you always
implement the moment you find out the
problem okay now let us say I am writing
a lot of repetitive classes in
implementations why can't I okay I have
a ICICI Bank here also I have withdraw
here also I have uh check balance here
also I have
deposit method I have one more class I
have one more class I have 10 classes
can I have one interface which takes
away all these repetitive things from
that if I uh let's say Implement all of
them won't it serve my purpose or won't
it help me in future designs it
definitely does what it does it will ask
all the other classes who are actually
in like implementing them it gives you
some kind of a feature wherein you need
to bound to that interface and must and
must and must you have to implement
those methods
this is a one of the common pattern I'm
giving you an example what you people
can understand you can understand what
is an interface you will can understand
what is a class so with this correlation
I'm talking about this what does
patterns capture patterns capture design
expertise and allow that expertise to be
communicated and it promotes main point
remember design reuse and avoid mistakes
that is what we captured and we are
educating people to know this to
actually use in their day-to-day lives
or decoding
it improves documentation okay and
understandability
so if you understand real the pattern
well
the moment you write the documentation
you are sorted because you know what
statements to use how do I document them
because I know those patterns now I have
understood them it is just that I have
to implement the right way okay now
that's about benefits of using patterns
now
we got this how many design patterns we
have okay this um
there are four people back then okay
Google this you will get to know gof
gang of four these people have come up
with this
different types of designs creation
patterns
structural patterns and behavioral
patterns
okay what does creational patterns says
whenever you create an object okay it
helps you to abstract the object
instantiation sorry is abstracting the
uh the object
methods are during creation
Builder talks about specifically about
the instantiation
fact 3 and Abstract Factory doctor about
abstraction
Singleton talks about how to keep one
object for everything
likewise every design pattern talks its
own point in themselves okay that's what
creational patterns are for today
example let me pick Singleton on Factory
and I'll explain you in detail okay
next what is structural pattern these
patterns won't talk about creation of
object remember that is the reason this
this segregation I made here
TSL patterns means most likely I will be
specified in creating the object during
that point of time they help me
okay next is structural patterns these
patterns mostly will help me
during the
flow of the after creation if I have to
do some specific operations okay how can
I come how can I switch okay you you
know this adapter right today we have
I let's say I have my
USB charger with me okay USB cable with
me okay and let's say my nowadays
earlier days you add earphones with 3.5
mm Jack correct
nowadays it got replaced with
type c
ports
can you really use those earphones with
latest today's phones you can for that
what you need an adapter okay
even though you are
earphones is not compatible you can use
something called as adapter and you can
use the latest phones with adapting them
themselves to
latest phones technology and how do you
do that and that is what this pattern
specified about
decorator let us say you have some
classes if you're I don't want to go in
detail of it so if you want to decorate
you can definitely do it under a facade
flyweight proxy
I there are a lot of it okay if if I go
down add time I would have explained
everything to you let's move on further
next is
behavioral pattern okay I'll pick up
Observer pattern what is Observer
pattern you have this
cricket match going on okay
cricket match is going on in this in the
stadium okay
you are subscribed for score updates
the moment there is a score update
happens you get that update how you are
an observer observe you have that means
you have registered it is all
subscription model you have subscribed
yourself to
one class and that class the moment it
gets updated update from other class it
just informs all of you guys you guys
may not be one okay you may be hundreds
or lakhs or crores for whatever people
who have subscribed or if you open Quick
Info you are already a subscriber by
default okay you are waiting for that
score to come on your screen that is
exactly is what Observer pattern will do
now what is China's responsibility now
in this one let us say you have sequels
of actions action one action two action
three action 4 okay I'll tell you an
example of browser window opens okay
then left panel opens then let's say
you're opening a Gmail Gmail box
the moment you click on Gmail like sign
in I am just giving you a scenario first
you have to load the left pane then you
offload the the male body and then you
upload the top most assign in box
these three should happen in sequences
what is requirement is now what pattern
I will use it for these two
make it work the best pattern will be
set of responsibility one after the
other I will go and pick up
so these are the
main patterns what we have with us okay
these are the it is sorry one more is
okay the behavioral structural and yes
now I will talk about one common pattern
all of you know I know you should know
this because you if you are a Java user
you will definitely know this pattern
okay that's what called as iterator
pattern in iterator pattern what does it
do
anyone if you guys know the answer I
would like to listen to all your answers
what do you understand by iterator
pattern is the question okay see if I I
want to talk about this if you guys
don't know no problem see first of all
iterator pattern
tells you to how to Traverse collection
observe here I have a list set map
stack queue lot of different
design sorry collections we are
the moment I call iterate The Collection
iterator it will give me iterator it
it's smartly identifies how to navigate
them internally okay it understands you
use iterator this whatever collection
you provide me I will be smart enough to
make sure you I will return a new
respective
next pointers okay let us say I'll given
a reality example how this works okay
now if you see this this you guys might
have definitely seen in your code a lot
of different things
an object that provides a standard way
to examine all the elements in any
collection may be
array so arraylist linked list
or stack queues whatever sorted sets
every anything
here
any collection uniform interface for
traversing many different data
structures to support concurrent
iteration and Elementary in one okay
so this is what interactive pattern we
know this because you do iteration
around the collections right and can we
have a pattern for this yes and is it a
repetitive problem observe your what I
told you guys before
like this
we are trying to bring the repetitive
things recurring software structure okay
that can be I I told you so many times
so
we identify repetitive things and make
it as a pattern okay
promotes design reuse yes definitely
reusing concept of iteration
so this is what it says look at that
says set dot iterator map dot iterator
these are the ways to use iterators it
smartly understands you are trying to
trade our set I want to use this
okay if it's a list I want to use this
and there are three methods which comes
to our rescue for this use case one is
as next what is this as next as next
will do what it will check for any
collection whatever you give do I have
any next element in the collection or
not if it exists let us suppose if it
exists then I will get the collection
and make sure I access first element in
that collection and it can be of account
to type look at this my internet error
is not just working for a specific type
it is giving me the kind of iterator I
want okay let us suppose I have list of
accounts like this
okay
list of account
new
a list
is how you create the object correct so
if you want an iterator you can say
is equals to
accounts Dot
method name is you can just call
operator
and to generally get of this type
it's what it's mentioned here
okay
same that got iterator will give you
that iterator okay object and now using
this you can perform two things
as next what does next we'll do it will
check
weather
we are
any
elements in the
connection or not
yes
our next ITR
dot next what whatever but that we have
that is next which will directly give me
next element
wired to this example because
most of you are familiar with this
iterator that is why I took this as my
first example which will make you guys
life easier to understand okay so that's
what this iterator pattern is all about
okay
now
before I go to Observer I will talk
about next pattern and that is Singleton
pattern
how a Singleton pattern works so what is
the purpose of Singleton pattern I'll
explain that to you guys also
let me create a single class uh or I
would say I'll create a package over
here
to increase the foreign
okay now let us say I have this
Singleton object I am making it as now
how can I achieve this and you guys tell
me how can I what is the meaning of
Singleton one class for the entire
duration okay
Singleton pattern is the simplest
pattern actually speaking
so if you want this I'll just put it
across here some point
so that you all will be able to follow
okay
again too much
create an object while making sure
this class provides me a way to access
its only object remember it is it's only
object which can be accessed directly
without needing to instantiate the
object again and again that means
single object
toward thee
maybe session or whatever and give you
an example that's it
so how can you achieve this how can can
you restrict creation of object
can you guys think about it how do I
create an object using what
using
Constructor right
if I block this it will it help me
certainly like me look at this now I
will add the Constructor over here it's
very good now I will create let me
remove this
public from here and I will just
Maybe
Singleton
example class I'll make here I'll make
it as public
public class
so I'll make like this
first try to create Main
now you see
am I able to create the class
object is equals to new
Singleton class
now object one
object two
hash code of object one is
observe here this will be definitely
different that means this is a normal
way of creating class here I am not
doing anything otherwise you only see
here okay both of them are different but
what is my purpose single objectization
so I should block this
block creating
object how can I do this
linear ideas any clue
by making this
instructor
private if you block creating object
only it will never
no one will get to know create this
particular object look at this the
moment I make this private see I got
this problem now it is your
responsibility that you will be able to
resolve them out of it okay how do you
do this there are many ways there is
lazy loading there is early
initialization there is lazy resolution
I'll show you both the approaches first
I'll talk about
early initialization
so first of all create the object I need
to provide method okay what I'll do
I will actually create an object over
here
single object
is equals to Nu
instead because I can do this I can
create the object and I made it as
private that means no one can access now
so I can say
I will give I have blocked particular
object instantiation so I there should
be a way to invoke this particular guy
right how can I make this make there
also a strike rate and create a static
member
with this name say get instance and you
return this particular object okay this
way you can do this okay it is giving
problem anyone tell me why it's giving
problem because you are accessing a
non-static member inside a static member
that is why you are having this problem
how to fix this make this as also static
okay the making some static you can
obviously return this object over here
so now instead of me creating the object
with the help of the Constructor can I
call this git instance let us see
whether it works or not
I will replace this with
like this
does it help me you only have a proof
look at this
see observe now both the escorts are
same that means
whatever I created the object now is
able to not just two okay even though if
I create one more object object
and it will also be same okay
there are multiple ways of improving
this
what happens here
is not a good practice you are not even
calling this get instance before that
only during the runtime only or creating
the optical sleeping detail and that is
not a good practice but not a good
design I mean in a single terminal these
are the other problems you have okay how
can you avoid this you can actually make
a task lazy initialization lazy
initialization
how do you achieve this I'll comment
this for a while
and then I will cut this
and
I will check first if
single object is null
only then
assign it and then
turn it
okay why this is required you guys tell
me let us say okay now let me do one
thing I'll do like this okay every time
someone calls me I keep on passing it
across let's see what happens
they are getting different Dash codes
and that is wrong that is defeating the
purpose of Singleton pattern
observe the the property over here it
just defeated my purpose if I make a
small mistake of passing them as it is
what is the reason you check
each object is null
only then create once next time onwards
don't initialize this guy
okay that is why we call it as lazy
initialization
okay and that's what he's doing here
now you notice
all of them are back to the original
date of Singleton object okay these are
two different ways of creating our
second way is the better way of dealing
with Singleton objects wherein you
create object only when someone invokes
this particular class okay so that is
the main difference between early
initialization and lazy initialization
using Singleton pattern okay so I hope
you guys have understood this design
pattern yes
okay I can take one more example
let us see it's just eight minutes left
maybe I will take uh
Factory pattern and quickly explain
I'll try quickly to explain to you guys
let us see okay now
next I will talk about Factory pattern
what is Factory pattern let us say you
have a common use case across every
everyone that means
you are creating the object for
repetitive use cases that means we
create object without exposing creation
logic
my client should never know how I am
creating the object is only bothered
about you want the object
with a common interface okay I'll show
this use case to you guys quickly
I'll just create a class called as
Factory pattern demo
here let me or add all the things
interface I'll add a chip interface here
I will keep it simple I'll keep it okay
in the shape interface I will say add a
draw method
simple parameter I've added
okay I don't want to complicate here
that's why I added a simple draw method
then I have let me add
a different maybe three different
classes what shapes are very famous
so class maybe Circle
I'll implement this
okay
okay the moment to implement them I have
to implement those methods also so this
country pattern
I will share everything code example
slide everything I'll share what will I
do with using this all these things
so I will say this is
from
Circle
okay
now I will replicate aim for
rectangle
and also I'll replicate same for maybe
where
all of them are implementing same
interface observed this this and this
are implementing same thing
now let me create a factory okay what is
what is the purpose of factory I have a
I am a person who is client I say give
me an object of circle should give me I
say give it a bit of
rectangle it should give me okay I'll
show the example of this example here
from Main here I say
I want shape of circle you give me how
do you want I say maybe get shape
I don't know how you get me the same
shape I say circle with a shape I will
say
that angle do give me the shape okay we
are generalizing here we are actually
hiding the details of creation
so however we are adding I will show you
shortly I will implement the factory who
returns the right object whenever you
get this okay I will say class
shape Factory
here I say oblique
it will return the shape
and I say get shape going to return it
will take
string
okay what is the type you are expecting
if you don't pass anything to me
I don't provide anything to you
let us say
switch statement
of
shape
this is of
let me say I am passing the circle over
here
then I return
okay I will have to
I'll say
shape
current shape
is equals to
new I say
Circle over here it doesn't matter me
okay you can do this
and you can say
break
okay this is for the this shape
particular shape
maybe we can repeat this for
the rectangle
also we can repeat this for
so I say Square
rectangle
square if nothing is passed
so default
applying it to null
and break it okay instead of writing if
yes I have written this switch case
so now this is mentioned you can remove
this remove that particular thing and
you will return the current shape okay
so I have written this shape Factory
this shape Factory okay in future if you
want I will give you that respective
type
whenever you ask me so now I can instead
of creating
shape every single time my job is now
very simple
I will do come here and I say Factory
equals to new shape Factory
to call this with that's it and you call
like this and you call like this and you
call like this to the square as the name
of the variable okay
now you I invoking the parameter from
all of them
but angle Square
let us verify what output we are getting
observe
this from Circle which is from rectangle
this is from Square observe here what
just happened for us
we
need to get the shape from this guy in
given us a shape and it went on to call
their respective classes which I am
least bothered as a client okay this is
the client class actually
client doesn't know how you are building
the class he's only bothered about a
class which he wants okay he it's your
responsibility whatever you define in
the Clusters I want this particular
shape you give me the shape that's all
you ask for okay and that is what an
example of or easy example of
Factory pattern
this is something called as abstract
Factory pattern now you have one Factory
like this if Factory only becomes common
that also you can create one more
pattern okay and that design pattern is
known as
abstract Factory pattern
okay so I hope these two examples are
given you better understanding of how
can you go about with the help of
desired patterns okay it is very very
very important guys to understand this
okay
good now
I will I'll stop here I'll take up the
questions
so
yeah and I've got uh some of them queued
up already
um
we had several questions for adventra
about languages is or language
is there a need to
keep track of what languages are popular
or
that
pretty much
um
independent of
what people will ask and
actually see programming language is
just a Syntax for your expressing your
understanding that's it okay programming
language is never important if you
understand the logic behind it design
patterns is applicable
for language agnostic it's not language
dependent even though you understand in
any language you can definitely make
person or your requirement satisfied or
answered with the with the understanding
you have so it is language agnostic
and
entry
shift in in languages is
fairly rapid and constant exactly
so
you you may be an expert in Python
programming for example
but python we don't know what the runway
is for how long it's going to be the
language of choice and uh
context so
you need to be able to express the
as Rick Bender described it the design
principles
and that level of understanding
independent
of languages so that's a that's
something to keep
in mind
um
we have Psy who asked uh I don't have an
experience can I get a job with a 2018
pass out
what would you advise someone yeah I
think you can answer this to it like see
my answer for this would be very simple
okay so if you if you have a right
degree and if you drive simply learn and
get this knowledge out of this six
months or eight months whenever you
complete it then definitely you will be
getting a job for sure
yeah
um the the concept is
that if you have the skills it's still a
seller's market for labor so that means
that there are employers out there who
are looking for people
um even though we are looking at the
potential for a recession next year and
we're hearing stories about
layoffs at Main companies the the
reality is that when that happens many
other smaller companies that had been
trying to recruit
now have the opportunity to snap up
people coming into the market so
it's always a situation of creative
destruction so to speak technology
industry where
um
meta decides to de-emphasize the
metaverse and
um
releases a number of developers then
what happens is that other companies
start having availability to develop
their
Concepts and their products so it's a
like I said it's a it's a it's still a
market that favors employees
um
Manu asks a question as you were going
through better design the better design
always mean less redundancy
less redundancy always assigned a better
design
no it's not written against these all
together are different negative word
reusabilities all together a beautiful
word okay do not love these two and get
confused design patterns helps you to
improve or recommend reusability whereas
redundancy is a term where it is used
you are repeating yourself a lot so
that's what experience is all about okay
yeah
it's interesting because
on a systems level there's also the the
meaning of redundancy as you know
survivability through having backup
systems and that type of thing but in in
this discussion today we're talking
about uh why have the same
um
well I have repetitive code doing
similar functions when you can have
reusable code that saves you all the
extra effort extra
memory the the
excellent point
[Music]
um
so Manu asked whether you'd be able to
share the coding examples you've done I
don't know do we have a mechanism for
that or not
uh I didn't get that question come again
with the question Stuart I was not able
to find it mono and the chat asks if you
if you if there was a way for you to
share the uh
coding examples you just did sure sure I
can send it across to you maybe you guys
are in a better place to pass it on to
them
we'll be sending a follow-up email out
uh after this session
with links to the uh
PowerPoint slides and uh
our vendor can share the code examples
with me I'll include that as well
everything
okay
and let's see what else is coming in
through the chat
I need to expel that
guys a recession will happen for sure
okay
but the demand for knowledge
knowledgeable Talent developers are
definitely there okay if you see layoffs
right layoffs are not happening for
every area it can happen for a lot of
different reasons in layoffs are not
always directly proportional decision as
of today so the factors are different
and developers are the last people to be
thrown out of the company okay this is
mark my words they are the last you guys
are being one of developers they are
always in a good state to be to survive
in the industry okay and if you have
knowledge why to worry let's even though
layoff comes you can find the next job
in in quite some time
yeah I mean that's that that is the
point I was trying to make earlier is
that um
the there's a a constant process of new
things emerging
um
before 2009
nobody conceived of what uh Facebook
would be in the in terms of its scope
and size
um and it hasn't been that long did it
take very long for it to Blossom and
become what it is today well right now
there are other
platforms other companies other products
that are just emerging that are going to
have the same type of explosive growth
they're going to be looking for a
technology staff so it's always a
process of
as
some companies go through the
difficulties of being large and adapting
to changing markets other companies
emerge and start absorbing any excess
labor that's in the field
um
so we had a couple of questions that
related to data science and I just
wanted to clarify
um
the DSA
topic that we had advertised is not
about data science per se about data
structures and algorithms which is a
software development topic but we do
have
um various data science webinars coming
up and I'll be talking about that in
just a minute
upcoming months I'm talking about solid
principles I'll be talking about hlds
DSC a lot of different topics where that
might really help you to understand that
better okay yeah
with me which I can want to share with
you guys definitely we can keep this uh
rolling okay I'm going to go ahead and
move on to the end of the presentation
I'm going to share the last Stuart I
shall I drop off if it's fine uh it's
all right if you do but thank you very
much vendor for being here today I
really appreciate that and we're looking
forward to uh future sessions with you
as well thank you so much I wish you all
the very best for all of you guys
uh this is a wonderful platform make
good use of it and all the best thank
you
thank you so much
um so as I mentioned um we have some
upcoming webinars and I also want to
mention the um
full stack Java developer master's
program this is a program if you are in
India
this program can be done as a
job guarantee program
which means that for Learners in India
specifically we have agreements with
companies uh hire folks in India so you
have to be either resident there have
the right to work there
in order to get the job guarantee for
anyone else outside of India the uh Java
developer Masters program very valuable
but doesn't include job assistance and
less but not job guarantees so I just
want to make that clear but this is a
six-month program that
takes you all the way through
if you are not yet conversant in all
these tools it will expose you to them
make you use them in different exercises
in Labs so that when you finish this
course
and uh
complete
certification you'll be able to claim
with backup that you have used these
tools and can show
these skills so it's just a
great program it has 26
integrated projects and labs
it's all delivered online
you can take it from anywhere in the
world
on your laptop on your desktop a lot of
the material is even accessible on a
mobile device
um and
it gives you as I mentioned for Learners
in India in the USA there's job
assistance
where there's a version in India that is
a job guarantee program so
we're
very proud of that
and
just based on what I've said on this
very brief introduction I just want to
get a quick pull of the audience whether
this is something that might interest
you
so is this something
that you might want to enroll in
without making a commitment
here's a question
leave it open for another 15 seconds
okay
get those last
answers in and
here is the result
so about two-thirds of the people
responding said that they'd be
interested we will be glad to send you
information about that but you can also
contact us at ask us simplylearn.net
put that information into the chat box
for you
um
so that you can both
look at the program
and on the website as well as
contact our learning Consultants by
email
and get your answer questions answered
so
as I did mention there are
upcoming webinars next week
one is about career potential in cyber
security for 2023
and another one is on digital marketing
uh the week after we'll have a
expert webinar in the area of uh
artificial intelligence and data science
to keep your eyes open for that I'm
going to put the information about these
two webinars into the chat right now
so that you have the links that you can
go to
get information and register if you're
interested
yeah this is all part of our ongoing
program of three webinars for people in
the industry
so do keep an eye out
connect with us on Facebook at
simplylearn or Twitter at simplylearn
connect with our LinkedIn Pro page uh
simply learn on LinkedIn and we'll keep
you uh informed about future webinars
and uh course availabilities and we hope
to welcome you into the simply learn
ing Community thank you all very much
for being here today from wherever you
are in the world
and this concludes our webinar for today
so thank you